yeah welcome to this video let's play d4
p.m. haga from spain on yeah i don't
know i think i played this guy always
with black i was just thinking what line
is he playing and i recall that he's
playing b 31 b 3 all the time but i
didn't really remember what he's playing
is black so prolly I always have wide
air black against him okay we got the f3
nims oh and he played them this somewhat
old-fashioned out of fashioned line and
castles is really weird I mean you you
you usually play that to go to e5 and I
think now maybe if I've is also what ash
what I should play on c5 now i have d 5
i'm not sure what what what's the big
idea that black hands here maybe you can
play f6 and try to get some counter play
know this is maybe Wow c6 okay yeah ok
this is really am somewhat provocative
just intending Queenie form swinging
over to the kingside Queenie for f5 text
takes Queen edge form well this this is
dangerous okay keep it simple doesn't
what okay okay maybe he's got 95 this
could be a could be one IDM 95 takes
Knight eggs and then I'm forked here on
the Queen and the bishop
otherwise just bishop age six and and
blackest black is in terrible shape I
mean I can do that I can do that anyway
but nice 95 is something that might be a
might be an issue so maybe I should just
um I just just just move from the Queen
away from 95 tricks f5 I can take now
andy sixx is hanging so um okay now his
idea is probably too so go f5 okay i
want to get rid of this bishop anyway f5
yeah this is interesting now i can take
which isn't bad oak or queen each form
and i think i must opening up the
position must be the right one so now
he's in this pin cannot move the light
now and okay this is clear see if I like
if i take this d3 hanging but of course
I don't want d fibers to move that down
that release screams to be played
okay come on t5 it takes I go 95 and now
I'm that's the first sacrificing
sacrifices I'm looming Nigeria Bishop um
g6 okay so what now night g6 Bishop g6
so it's all very dangerous ok let's take
with the night I mean I cannot calculate
this now just a matter of of time and
the splits game both are so obviously
dangerous and hard to determine if if
one of those moves is winning on the
others not let's uh let's just try this
one yeah okay i don't i don't want to
I want to take only seven I mean this is
just just stronger I think threatening
97 double check cannot play King h8
cannot move the King anyway and if it
takes Queen takes and then Luke f6 let's
just just made now probably this is
strong don't see it defense ready to 97
yeah don't see move probably this
winning double check as some it's quite
something and of course there's also
night f8 or something if you post Bishop
tutu g6 for example I can just take
evade maybe there's something better
even but neither f8s is enough yeah this
is double check as mentioned and now
Queen e5 Knight f6 we have six and
resigns yeah he simply you cannot play
play this way in the opening this is
this is too much already I think hard to
defend this and I got a summer half a
simple attacking plan let's just check
this check this briefly with with the
computer he's got something to say about
that computer wants to go nitey to hear
also looks like a good move really but I
think this should be fine also the ID is
winning + + 2 something and now it gives
Bishop g6 winning okay well let's hope
that this okay this wins as well okay so
it wasn't it wasn't it was bad what I
played but this this this loses out
right the computer once wants to defend
with with another booth
computer once play this what yeah he
wants to check here Bishop here and yeah
only with plus two this is the line that
that it is giving dad it's still pretty
horrible now okay so nice attacking game
maybe he simply confused something here
with castles this is some the the move
you need to play and now in this
position is let's just put it on the
board he need you need to play this move
here to force why to take to advance the
pawn and then you've got a close center
and don't have to worry about any attack
on the king yeah thanks for watching
this